hey welcome back some gadget lab I'm
Mike Isaac I'm like glory and this week
what are we got going on Oh amazon
tablets maybe you heard yeah amazon has
come out with their their version of the
android tablet right along with a whole
family of new kindles yeah that was the
kind of the big surprise we all kind of
knew that amazon was working on an
android tablet for some time or there
have been rumors of it for some time but
this whole three like three new kindles
right that are coming they've taken the
regular kindle and sort of made it a
little bit smaller made some hardware
changes to it and that is going to be
eighty dollars and then there are two
versions of a touchscreen kindle what's
that called it's called the kindle touch
okay one of them is a hundred dollars
and that's Wi-Fi only and then there is
an option with 3G wireless connectivity
so you can buy books while you're
sitting on the beach and that one is one
hundred fifty dollars and then the fire
is the two-hundred-dollar tablet
amazon's probably taking a hit on the
hardware rights under for two hundred
dollars nice and cheap just to get it
into people's hands yeah they're I mean
they're approach is sort of kind of like
the opposite of apples right Apple is
going for this high-end starting at five
hundred dollar premium tablet and
Amazon's doing the exact opposite we're
going for a two hundred dollar price
point whether or not they're taking some
have speculated a fifty-dollar hit on
each tablet you know we obviously we
don't know for sure but it's I think
it's a smart approach you know you want
to push this tablet this one android
tablet into as many hands as you can I
think that's the seems like the right
price to do it at all so it's not an
iPad it doesn't have a camera it doesn't
have GPS it doesn't have too many
external or any external options for
adding things like SD cards USB sticks
things like that so it's basically just
meant to be consuming things mostly from
the cloud right exactly and that's their
Amazon sort of strengthen this whole
thing and I think this is this is what
makes them I don't wanna say Dark Horse
Billy may be a white horse and just just
as a sort of powerful contingent
because they're essentially a sort of
content media company right they have
streaming video they have an mp3 store
they have their own android app store
don't forget about books money have also
read apparently people still read no I
and they they have essentially all the
things that Apple as well offers right
but a manufacturer like samsung or
motorola you know they they are also
producing tablets android tablets but do
they have any of this stuff no you know
they have a partner with people so
amazon has the whole channel wrapped up
and i think people would be pretty
excited I don't know what are you more
excited about the kindle touch the cheap
kindle or the kindle tablet honestly I
imac i'm kind of stoked on the new kent
the super cheap Kindles like what it
barred me from doing that before is like
oh do I want to spend you know 100 bucks
or however much to bring an e-reader to
the beach but for eighty dollars or
something that I really don't even I
won't cry if I drop in the ocean or get
sand in or something like that I think
that's cool and I think it's going to
get so many more Kindles into millions
of people's hands that it's just gonna
be so ubiquitous now check what does
barnes and noble do with the nook suffer
besides that's my prediction anyway well
your suffer well there's that was this
week's big announcement and there's
another big announcement next week yeah
we got something else going on Christina
will be able to talk about that but
first I think she's out jumping around
somewhere she's always out jumping
around all right go check in let's see
what's up
this is the belly con mini trampoline
activities like running can be really
hard on your joints your knees your
ankles the belly con smooth out that
landing so there's not as much pressure
on your joints this is no ordinary
trampoline instead of springs it uses
individual bungee cords to attach the
jumping surface to the metal frame it's
a great way to get light to moderate
aerobic exercise without busting your
joint or making a lot of noise it comes
in a couple different sizes depending on
your height and weight and it'll run you
just under seven hundred dollars
well that was cool and I like what you
did with your hair you got to tell me
how you did that Thanks I know and now
my voice is gone yeah what happened are
you smoking too much again I guess so
I'm like a sexy smoker exactly Kathleen
Turner anyway so Apple right Apple this
is next week we finally got ya we
finally got invites right we did tell me
about it Tuesday Tuesday down in
cupertino one influent infinite loop
apple's iphone event finally we're
finally gonna get to see the iphone 5 4
s whatever it is both of them one of
them no more iphone 5 rumors after this
yeah and how do we know that it's an
actual iphone i mean other than the
timing and things like that they hinted
in the invitation they did they the
invitation had an image of for app icons
and let's talk I fellow who ok well
there's there's some speculation around
even the phrasing of that too right and
I and I saw something about someone
analyzed what all that the apps meant on
there and what piece by piece those
people would be funny to grow lives we
don't have much money um so all right so
you're gonna be there on site we're
gonna I'm assume live blog this whole
thing yes and see it do you know if
there's any other speculation on what
what else we're going to see there um
it's mostly iphone focused we could hear
a mention about ipods normally the paula
vent is ipod focus okay ah so that's
kind of a change this year okay yeah and
I pods have been sort of dying off I'm
not dying off but they've been taking a
hit especially with the prominence in
the rise of the iphone right so maybe
Apple will have to try something
different with
maybe reduce the price or God knows you
know yeah can i pod TV touch yeah guess
we'll find out yeah cool so what else
you got so we also saw the debut of
windows phone mango this week oh yeah
what does that remind me it's a it's a
windows phone 7.5 it's a big update to
wind it the windows phone 7 operating
system okay cool so what does this mean
for the one percent of 117 owners out
there however many windows phones that
are not the owners up it means they are
getting what they've been asking for for
a while it's a it's a big update
microsoft really listened to users
complaints about Windows Phone 7 and
addressed pretty much every issue that
people had more were their complaints um
there were some issues about syncing
accounts on gmail calendars search
functionality for apps before you kind
of scroll through a big long list and
now there's a search button there's lots
I think they made something like 500
tweaks to the OS so there's a bunch of
things you know we probably don't even
notice little optimizations and that
just looks it just looks nice it really
does it's kind of to me it seems like
the anti iOS hmm a phone operating
system it's very Apple tells you you
know kind of this is how it is you know
people have you know they're different
iphones but pretty much everyone uses
them about the same way with driven yes
yeah with Windows Phone you can really
customize and personalize your phone
experience you can you've got these live
tiles on here and you can tap and hold
and rearrange them you know you can
decide you know what's more important
you know you can it's got this great
people hub which is where it keeps your
contacts and you can go through check
out what's going on on Twitter Facebook
email let's see you can if you click on
someone you've got a history with that
person or cool it is her goal someone
changed their profile picture okay oh
yes you can go through your history and
no sorry I died interesting to me nail
oh well that's cool I mean they did like
a whole sort of revamped interface I
mean yeah it's very social media
integrated everything is social media
these days but do you keep overall
impressions what do you think I think
it's absolutely fantastic good I really
do an endorsement it's it's great I like
it a lot it's very different it takes
some getting used to if you're used to
using iOS you might have some
preconceptions about how things should
work and you kind of nice gotta throw
those out the window cool well I guess
that'll be rolling out soon it's already
available and it's rolling out slowly to
the different windows phone 7 devices
okay of which there are you know a few
out there this is a samsung right yes
this is the Samsung Focus cool well all
you windows people Windows Phone people
you'll be getting that soon I'm sure oh
and just quickly the it also want now
also launched an app marketplace on the
web they did yes so now you can check
out apps reviews ratings online all
right cool I mean basically it sounds
like ketchup to Google and Apple who are
both well apples the furthest along of
anyone yeah but well we'll see I guess
we'll have to wait and see especially
after they it's slow death of webos
we'll see what windows does yeah anyway
thanks for comin on thank you guys for
watching and we will see you next week